[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el tema de
hoy es la rápida expansión de tres
variantes del coronavirus que ha hecho
aprender nuevamente todas las alarmas en
la comunidad internacional ante el temor
de que puedan complicar la gestión de la
pandemia que ya ha dejado más de 2.8
millones de fallecidos en todo el mundo
y más de 129 millones de personas
contagiadas se trata de las variantes
detectadas en reino unido- sudáfrica y
brasil que se caracterizan por una mayor
facilidad para transmitirse con respecto
a la de wuhan a según los estudios
realizados hasta la fecha para ello
conversamos con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia asesor
científico de france 24 doctor muy buen
día los casos de cobain 19 están
aumentando entre toda la población más
joven en países como brasil y colombia
según indican algunos estudios la
diferencia del inicio de la pandemia que
afectaba a los adultos mayores porque
estamos viendo esto
lo que está sucediendo es que obviamente
la población joven es mucho más densa es
mucho mayor número y se está afectando
por la que principalmente se está
infectando debido a sus actividades
económicas que han salido en vacaciones
aunque el estado en mayor contacto
interacción humana además de eso la
población mayor ya está recibiendo la
vacuna y por eso vemos menos casos en la
población adulta que se haya concentrado
en la población joven en lo esperado en
esta pandemia se ha visto en estos
países y seguramente hace el
comportamiento en el futuro ahora autor
le pregunto por qué países como
indonesia y tailandia comenzaron su
programa de vacunación a esta población
joven y viendo esto cuál sería el
programa de vacunación más adecuado
entonces
cada país dice una estrategia de acuerdo
a su biología consideraron inicialmente
en estos países que la población joven
era la principal población que podía
expandir el coronavirus sin embargo la
mayoría hemos reconocido que la
letalidad lo más importante y por eso la
prioridad de la población adulta al
personal de salud es fundamental en
nuestras economías en nuestro desarrollo
de la pandemia cada uno de los países
tiene una particularidad para nosotros
lo más sensato siempre va a ser primero
proteger a las personas que más se
mueren las personas que más se complican
las personas que pueden colapsar el
sistema de salud y en ellos la población
adulta y por eso de ahí la prioridad de
vacunación en este grupo poblacional
ahora autor en los países cristianos se
celebran la semana santa que para muchos
son unas vacaciones representa esto un
aumento de los casos de la enfermedad en
la población joven
sin duda este es un momento crítico
porque hay mayor interacción humana hay
mayor cantidad de en relaciones de
reuniones entre familias y eso puede
llevar a que haya más contagios esta
época de descanso a ser una época muy
crítica no es solamente el
comportamiento va a definir el futuro de
lo que pase en este par de semanas en la
pandemia pero no esperamos unas buenas
noticias porque el comportamiento pues
es digamos demasiado irregular en este
momento hay mucha interacción y
probablemente simplemente los casos
ahora hablemos de la tasa de
hospitalizaciones en esta población
joven le pregunto si se debe a la
agresividad de estas nuevas variantes
se ven dos cosas la primera que mayor
número de casos entonces al haber mayor
número el caso de la población joven
pues mayor personas se van hospitalizado
además de la población joven también es
población que tiene comorbilidades
empezadas plantas no tratadas
inmunosupresión que también las hacen
parte de este grupo hospitalización y
sin duda en los linajes virales que
tienen mayor efectividad en la
transmisibilidad y en la agresividad
también son un componente importante
porque la población joven no dice es en
tanto más ahora doctor por último que
recomendaciones le puede hacer a estas
personas jóvenes que posiblemente sean
las últimas en los planes de la curación
en la mayoría de los países
en este momento tenemos que conservar la
sensatez
no podemos perder todo lo que hemos
aprendido en este año el distanciamiento
físico el uso del cubrebocas el lavado
de manos y estar en espacios bien
ventilados debe ser permanente hasta que
logremos una inmunidad del 70 80 por
ciento de la población los niños
adolescentes jóvenes y adultos debemos
conservar las medidas de bioseguridad
para asegurar un futuro mejor y ojalá
así sea y todos tomemos conciencia de
doctor ante esta pandemia que nos afecta
a todos gracias por estar en 5 minutos
con buen día
[Música]